et uniquement aux i bonsoir bonsoir
ils m'ont soir bonsoir michel bonsoir
bonsoir alors il fais moi plaisir
dis-moi bonsoir comme tu dis bonjour
tous les jours à la télé bonsoir très
bien mais sans son de la vidéo
tu connais michel drucker revient poser
une question alors une seule sommes de
vieux complices pose une seule question
la fidélité à beille où je crois pose
une question doit maintenant comment
fait-il pour présenter le journal de la
mi journée de tf1 on n'est pas 2h30 du
matin presque tous les jours aux badauds
chine questions que j'avais préparé
vieilles habitudes des vieilles
habitudes
j'avais dit réflexe physiologique normal
ça ça me fascine totalement mais moi
aussi mais j'ai jamais compris comment
vous et moi je crois qu'il fait la
sieste l'après-midi en clair
non moi je crois que alors je vais je
vais répondre à une question que
beaucoup de gens notre profession se
poser aussi des téléspectateurs le
secret div 1 c'est qu'il doit à sa fille
d'un médecin qui vous le dit il doit
dormir peu un idiot a pas un vrai sommet
sur une distance courte et demande à sa
femme
voilà c'est ce qui fait la nuit ça on va
parler de ton bouquin qui changent chez
calmann lévy
qu'ils s'appellent hors antenne que tu
as fait avec malice achard ans assez
marrant il ya plein de petites anecdotes
comme ça sont tes débuts un sport
dimanche sur michel arnaud qui t'apprend
le boulot oui oui je fais un peu
province comme barma ici de me
l'apprendre
j'espère qu'il réussira aussi bien que
michel avec toi il ya plein d'histoires
qui sont très marrante
quand tu as failli virer gainsbourg
lui-même dean c'est assez beau ça parce
que tu dis j'aurais pu lui mettre mon
poing dans la gueule ça aurait fait
plaisir à la france profonde mais je
n'ai pas fait à l'ail effectivement dans
cette émission quand il à dire oui que
you say you like to fuck qu'est ce que
ça veut dire c'est parce qu'il veut dire
que dans ton livre tu traduis pas
vraiment à l'antenne j'ai dit
je vais vous traduire ce que dit
gainsbourg il vient me dire ce serait
bien faire un petit tour avec vous les
gars seconde vie où seul avatar et
attend les gaz bourg à 10 mais j'ai pas
dit ça j'ai dit que vu la baiser ouais
alors je dis nous étions une heure de
grande écoute moi j'ai dit oui il vient
de lui dire qu'il y aurait dû compter
fleurette il dit mais j'ai plus est mais
il le fera après il me dit non j'ai dit
aujourd'hui la baiser par après mais
tout de suite c'était une horreur
ouais et la fois en 30 secondes quand
j'ai vu le regard de whitney houston je
me suis dit tout le sort en dix ans
maintenant ça suffit
et tu fait un tabac le l'émission
s'arrête alors qu'il manque encore une
chanson avec eddy mitchell vous trouvez
ça des magouilles le sortir au jeu pas
mal non mais je disais j'ai pas fait
mais aller j'étais tenté quand même
non parce qu'il est sorti il ya quelques
jours et je crois je lance aux verts
demain aujourd'hui on lui il a fait un
livre c'est chez michel lafon
oui oui dis que finalement si le mathias
tu as pu atterrir sur la place rouge
c'est un coup monté
parce que comme ça gorbatchev a pu virer
son état-major c'est ça oui non mais
c'est pas mal comme idée
non mais c'est une idée est-ce que c'est
perdition détient couru dès le début
ouais ce qui m'amusait en réalité
c'était génial de voir une soirée au
bain lorsque médias c'est à dire
isolation la soirée au bain on se doit
et quelques copains et on bavarde de ce
fait divers que des inscrits comme tous
les journalistes dans la figue mûre avec
la une dépêche du midi et en fin de nuit
et commencé à délirer sur mais comme a
dû aller là bas et ce que je connais de
lui enseigner dit ce que je tenais
indigo des rapports avec les états
majors yéti de la nomenclature un unique
ce qu'ils n'avaient pas pu arriver
là-bas par hasard lors à partir de là
ont besoin ça y avait quelques cinéastes
dans le coin elle est une idée de
scénario dans laquelle il fallait
trouver une histoire qui se tiennent et
qui aboutit à l'arrivée de mathias sur
la place mais est ce que toi tu as pas
été manipulée par les russes pour que
finalement ils ont fait croire que ça
c'est possible seulement s'ils le
veulent bien
non dans cette première d'abord c'est un
livre de journalistes
ouais et étant journaliste et recevant
les dépêches
et connaissant un petit peu le système
soviétique n'y a pas un cessna
on pourra toujours me répondait ce qu'on
veut il n'y a pas un cessna global
saison de la chasse debré demandant le
système soviétique l'aider milan ac
entre une chasse qui prend en chasse un
cessna et le moment où il faut tirer il
faut qu'il y ait une décision alors ce
système hiérarchique se développe dans
10 15 il faut il ya le type présents
pour dire tiré seulement si doux
l'équipe sont d'absents ce jour là
personne ne dira c'est à travers ça que
j'ai imaginé l'histoire de mathias
travail vont jusqu'à la place pour bip
halde entretiennent de bonnes relations
avec le rss 2 0
c'est vrai qu'à mes athlètes de
lancement l'ambassade dur
excellente et je souhaite que le livre
soit lancé dassier dit ouais l'un des
premiers exemplaires jeu que j'ai
dédicacé était et médical siehm égale
gorber la question que je voulais te
poser parce que moi j'y pense tous les
matins en me réveillant c'est comment tu
fais drucker n'a posé tout à l'heure
quels secrets alors va nous le dire la
mémé ya pas de secret tu t'es là jusqu'à
4 heures du matin tu présentes le 13
heures le soir tu l'as dit non mais être
là avec moi là un enfant qu'on est trop
là je viens d'avoir du matin et driss ou
ailleurs ouais c'est aussi une
formidable école dort en moi je me
souviens des premiers scoops sais pas
raconter ma vie
tommy scène mais je raconterai peut-être
un nom mais là des premiers secours
mondiaux que j'ai pu faire à la
télévision michel s'en souvient de tête
c'est le moment où j'ai eu à 13 heures
enrique ce jeu qui m'a
en premier révélé le plan qu'il allait
chez régine je les trouvais chez régine
1 5 heures du matin avait fait le pari
que lui pour être pas se réveiller à
l'heure à laquelle je faisais mon
journal mais on a tenu le pari à 5
heures du matin et le lendemain j'avais
le scoop du plan des accords de mini
schools vachement tôt alors comment
commencer postiers que je suis sûr que
si drucker président journal il irait à
la pêche beaucoup plus souvent si on
veut pas être victimes les domaines du
mur il ya intérêt à être en permanence à
l'écouté
si je suis ici et s'il regarde par
exemple ce que tu fais sur la cinq de
base ne pas avoir laissé les votes mais
je dis que dans en matière de night
clubbing de regard sur une société qui
vit ton émission c'est à peu près la
même révolution que ce qui avait fait
dire dam dom dans ce que désire en même
temps très long il ya très longtemps bon
et la façon de traiter les invités la
nuit et cetera avec des hommes
politiques
c'est aussi révolutionnaire que dim dam
dom si on n'est pas à l'écouté de cela
ici on n'est pas dans l'environnement
-de fin il ya certainement un moment où
on ne pourra pas continuer parce que la
société va plus vite que ceux qu'ils ont
si elle va plus vite que ce que nous
disons nous ne pouvons pas à trancher
sur ce que disent les gens dans la rue
ce qu'on voit pas grand chose que disent
les gens dans la rue on n'existe plus
travail toi si tu as mis au boulot je me
suis mis au vote et mis au boulot avant
d'en faire avant avant le pot c'est déjà
du travail ou là maintenant oui je
travaille au nouvel obs
ouais c'est bien c'est une belle madame
tom toi comme comme journal la bière non
si je faisais une case son livre comme
un verrou à cet instant prix de
journalisme pas salarié à la pige
c'est bien quand on a tous commencé
comme ça tu sais mais bien quand même je
te dirai ceci dit ils demandent que les
grands interviewe immense tu va
interviewer qui l'a par exemple la de
niro c'est pas mal j'ai fait maintenant
que pourra et cinq ans pas de charme ça
va un filon avons repris 20 ans reste
propriété
kubrick et puis les terrains et pour
être sûr de ne rien rater de in a
l'habitude abonnez vous y mettez un
pouce bleus